bonjour à tous les Russes n'ont pas
traîné à peine les bureaux de vote
fermée qu'ils annoncent les résultats
préliminaires des pseudo référendum
tenus en Ukraine sans surprise le OUI au
rattachement l'emporte 96% d'après la
commission électorale russe le vote
était organisé à doniels qu'à Louhans
qu'à Carson azaporigia là où les Russes
occupent ces territoires Bruno Daru
bonjour les
issus de ce vote ne faisaient guerre de
doute oui alors l'issue de ce vote
effectivement ne faisait guerre de doute
alors les résultats sont
typiquement trop beau pour être vrai ou
pour être honnête comme on voudra ça
rappelle un peu l'époque soviétique
d'ailleurs on parlait à l'époque de
score à la soviétique entre 96 et 100%
bon ben là on y est et encore ce ne sont
pas les résultats définitifs puisque
pour le moment on est sur des
fourchettes portant sur à peu près 25%
des bulletins dépouillés enfin avec des
chiffres comme ça entre 96 et 98% on
comprend que le suspense est assez mince
et donc comme prévu et bien
sécuriser toute cette zone vous vous
souvenez au début de la guerre on se
disait c'est peut-être un des véritables
objectifs de Vladimir Poutine sécuriser
et voir annexer à la Russie l'Est et le
Sud du pays plus la Crimée ça fait un
espèce de continuum comme ça donc là ce
sont à peu près 15 % du territoire
ukrainien autour de 90 000 km² quand
même qui dans deux ou trois jours vont
devenir une partie de la Russie ce qui
permettra à Vladimir Poutine de dire que
désormais les attaques portées contre
ces territoires seront une attaque
contre l'intégrité territoriale de la
Russie et que donc la Russie peut
irriposter y compris avec l'arme
nucléaire et bien sûr ces résultats ne
sont pas reconnus par les Occidentaux